having acted unreasonably in their
approach to determination of the
application and subsequent actions
during the course of the appeal process
consequent the consequence of this is
the appellant has been caused to incur
unnecessary and or wasted expense
the framework requires that local
planning Authority should approach
decisions
on proposed developments in a positive
and creative way
further they should use the full range
of planning tools available and work
proactively with applicants to secure
developments that will improve the
economic social and environmental
conditions of the area
decision makers at every level should
seek to approve applications for
sustainable development where possible
this is a site allocated for residential
development the application is
consistent with the development plan it
was supported by extensive documentation
and Technical submissions which resulted
in no objection being received from any
statutory consult team and a
recommendation for approval from the
professional officers of the council
however the council refused the
application for seven reasons several of
those implicitly questioned the
sustainability of the site for
development and the footnote refers in
particular to reason three and seven
and appear to be in principle objections
to the extent that the reasons assert a
lack of information the council being
positive and creative ought to have
requested further information of the
applicant they should have provided the
opportunity for information to be
submitted to address any of the residual
concerns of members albeit the officers
were satisfied
more particularly
the councils on a reasonable Behavior
which the appellant seeks an award of
costs against it as follows
firstly
the council formally withdrew reasons
for refusal one three four five six and
seven on the 14th of December
and secondly the council's approach and
behavior in pursuing reason for refusal
too and there are several facets to this
first
a change set out in the council's
evidence to the inquiry to the expressed
terms of reasons refusal 2 which
asserted a lack of information in
relation to attenuation basins and a
claim of inappropriate development in
the green belt as a consequence
secondly
the fundamentally incorrect
interpretation of the relevant test in
paragraph 150 of the framework with the
council approaching the defense of
reason for refusal two on the basis that
preservation of openness required no
negative effect even to the smallest
degree
and thirdly an incorrect approach to the
interpretation of nppf Greenbelt policy
to import the need to give substantial
weight to any Greenbelt harm either in
the process of determining compliance
with nppf 150
or as an additional test even if
development is deemed to be appropriate
having applied the terms of nppf 150.
the council's late introduction so this
is another another strand of
unreasonableness beyond the green belt
point
the council's late introduction of
arguments as to conflict with several
local plan policies that were not in the
reasons for refusal in setting out its
position in the statement of common
ground which policies were not
subsequently pursued by the council and
Council of Fosters proof of evidence or
otherwise
and finally as a heading the council's
unreasonable approach and rejection of
the use of planning conditions
which were always able to address the
terms of reason for refusal 2 as drafted
which was the absence of information
leading to the Assumption the Assumption
of inappropriateness
so I provide a little more detail in
relation to each of those
and to declare man what I'm saying is
that there are one two three four topics
but the second one's got three bits to
it
so on the first topic the withdrawal of
the reasons one three four five six and
seven
paragraph zero four seven of the
guidance lists a range of behaviors
which may be regarded as unreasonable in
relation to procedural matters at an
appeal the guidance expressly includes
withdrawal of any reason for refusal as
on a ground for an award of costs
on the 22nd of November last year the
council's planning committee considered
a report of the assistant director of
planning and follow on legal advice that
have been received further to
considering these a motion was agreed
that the council would cease to pursue
all of its grounds of objection to the
appeal
that position wasn't in fact
communicated at that point to the
appellant but subsequently the council's
planning committee as we know reconvened
on the 13th of December and despite
having determined the withdrawal of all
of the reasons members backtracked and
determined to continue in to pursue
reason two
the resultant position of the council
was communicated to the appellant on the
14th of December last year
and we say the council acted
unreasonably in refusing the application
for the withdrawn reasons of refusal
it recognized this in withdrawing those
reasons they were untenable by the time
of withdrawal the appellant had already
been put to the cost and expense in
addressing them in the preparation for
the appeal to be submitted the
appointment or reappointment of
professional team on those matters in
drafting the statement of case which was
an extensive document and went with
um and the statement of common ground
and significant work on survey efforts
by the professional team to respond to
those matters
so the appellants therefore seek an
initial partial Award of cost to reflect
all one work done I should say
um
expended and time and work expanded in
relation to the withdrawal of reasons up
to the 14th of December
um by that stage the appellant's
evidence was in substantial progress and
this relates to both substance and
procedure the substantive matter is that
the reason should never have been put
forward in the first place in the
procedural point is the late
communication of the inevitable
but in addition to that although the
council had indicated it no longer
wanted to defend those reasons because
the appeal had to continue to address
the remaining reasons and because the
nature of the appeal is such that it is
to the Secretary of State in fact to you
on the Secretary of State's behalf as
though a new application to be
determined
and I referred to this in opening it
section 79 one of the ACT
so the appellant had no realistic choice
but to provide evidence on these matters
further the withdrawn topics were
progressed during the course of the
inquiry by interested parties through
written submissions
presentations were made by several
individuals in relation to distinct
topics which included those to which the
withdrawn reasons had related
it's clear that the appellant had no
choice but to respond consequently there
was a continued need to call Expert
Witnesses on these technical matters
on topics the council had set running
with the reasons for refusal
without prejudice to the claim for costs
related to all dirt work done on all
areas that were withdrawn therefore the
appellant also seeks a partial Award of
costs to reflect all work done we
between the withdrawal reason sorry the
withdrawal of reasons and the end of the
inquiry in relation to those topics
I then turned to the second head which I
said has got three parts to it
so this is in relation to the council's
approach to Greenbelt
the residual reason for refusal reason
two relates solely to that part of the
proposed development which comprises
sustainable drainage basins and which
the green belt
sorry within the green belt reason for
refusal 2 States that no details of the
nature or scale of Works necessary to
form them has been submitted therefore
and I place emphasis on the word
therefore it is concluded that without
information to the contrary the
application would fail to preserve the
openness of the green belt and conflict
with its purposes
the council's reasons refusal was based
on the premise that the lack of
information allowed an assumption that
the development would not meet Greenbelt
policy and could not be approved this is
unreasonable the submitted information
was sufficient to enable the accounts to
conclude as to the appropriateness of
the proposed development the information
submitted included and you have a note
of it in due course but it's what that
information was I'm not going to read it
all out
um they had enough uh if they needed
anything else they should have said so
and they did not however and this is the
point of the costs a case actually
Advanced has changed
it's now the case the proposal is
claimed to be inappropriate on the basis
of the information available at the time
not the lack of information
councilor Foster's position in
cross-examination was that members
always had a clear view of what Subs
would be and that the committee had
enough information at the time to make a
decision
a reason for refusal has an effect Been
Changed by councilor Foster without any
Authority from the council to do so or
endorsement from the planning committee
that change did not receive endorsement
either at the November or December 22
committees and Council of foster has not
sought endorsement or approval of his
position in light of the new materials
submitted to the Council on the 3rd of
February
has been an unreasonable and unendorsed
change of position and the appellant has
been put to additional costing trying to
address the shifting case this is a
substantive claim of unreasonableness
and is for a full Award of costs
the second Green Belt Point relates to
preserving openness
whilst it was accepted by the council at
the inquiry that the proposed
attenuation basins are engineering
operations and have the potential to
fall within paragraph 150 of the
framework the council has misdirected
itself as to the proper test of
preserving openness
this is apparent in Council of Foster's
evidence a paragraph 8.8 and his
approach will have colored the judgment
to teach at every stage of the council's
decision-making process
the basis of the council's case has been
that the term preserve openness means
not at all negatively affecting it even
to the smallest degree
paragraph 47 of the guidance makes that
behavior which is acting contrary to or
not following well-established case law
regarded as unreasonable behavior and
giving rise to a possible Award of costs
here the case law is clear openness does
not mean freedom from development
preserving openness means keeping it
safe from harm rather than maintaining a
state of things
the other work in other words there is a
threshold of change acceptable before
harm occurs
that is the only proper and valid
interpretation of nppf 150 which allows
in principle a range of things that are
bound to affect openness
despite the law policy and its
application in other cases the council
is fundamentally misdirected itself as
to the right approach to the
interpretation of green belt policy
councilor Foster confirmed that he had
been advised the approach he was
asserting was the approach the council
always adopted
the council's unreasonable approach and
failure to consider the confirmed legal
position in relation to the test has
caused the appellant of necessary
expense in producing evidence which sets
out the established case law indeed this
is a substantive unreasonableness and it
relates to a full Award of costs because
it goes to the heart of the sole
remaining reasons for refusal
the third Green Belt related point is in
relation to paragraph 148 of the nppf
the council has unreasonably asserted
that the application must be assessed
against paragraph 148 of the npps
the council have maintained such an
approach despite the appellant
evidencing well-established case law to
the contrary
the course of appeal decision in Lee I
think that's actually two e's rather
than Lea Valley Regional Park Authority
the council's case seems either to be
that the substantial wait is to be given
to Greenbelt harm sorry the council's
case
seems either to be that substantial
weight is to be given to any Greenbelt
harm either as part of determining the
tests of paragraph 150 or as an
additional matter even if the outcome of
applying 150 is that the development is
not inappropriate
once development is considered not an
appropriate pursuant to the test in
paragraph 150 of the framework there is
no requirement to further assess harms
to the green belt this is because the
development is deemed appropriate
as to its impact on the Green Mount nor
can the nppf-148 approach which is all
about weighing very special
circumstances be imported into 150 as an
approach
Council of Fosters evidence and
correctly addresses the relevant tests
in relation to Greenbelt this is perhaps
understandable given he's not a
professional witness but the Appellate
notes the council did have the benefit
of a planning consultant who attended
the full duration of the inquiry but did
not give evidence the council's approach
led to it misdirecting itself as to the
correct interpretation of Greenbelt
policy
Mr Howlett did in due course confirm the
council's acceptance that once
development is deemed acceptable in
terms of impact on Greenbelt then the
assessment process ends there but that
is not
that was not until after Mr Foster had
given evidence and does not take away
from the unreasonableness of refusing
and continuing to defend that refusal
based on an error
and then come to the
third main topic outside the green belt
topics
during the appeal process and
negotiations on the statement of Common
Ground the council required several
local plan policies to be referenced as
reflecting their position and discussed
on the basis of being in dispute
these are summarizing the statement of
common ground at paragraph 8.2 but they
are also littered through the rest of
the statement of common ground
case
sorry council's Case in relation to the
statement has come out ground throughout
that document
these policies are not in the reason for
refusal they were never authorized to be
added to the reasons to refusal by any
committee and were not Advanced at all
in the council's evidence they are
policies ss1 SS2
ss9sp4 and even parts of lc1
the council has fundamentally failed to
advance any case on these policies
the appellant was therefore forced to
spend considerable time reviewing these
local plan policies and ensuring the
appellant's proof of evidence addressed
them
the appellant incurred wasted expense
through time spent addressing additional
policies which was subsequently not
referred to by the council during the
inquiry at all
this is a past reward of course in
relation to the time spent on that topic
and lastly I turn to the question of
conditions
paragraph 49 of the guidance lists a
range of behaviors that may give rise to
substantive Award of costs against a
council it expressly includes refusing
planning permission on a planning ground
capable of being dealt with by
conditions where it is concluded that
suitable conditions would enable the
proposed development to go ahead
aside from the council's ability to ask
for further information of the
application stage there was a clear
opportunity open to the council to Grant
planning permission subject to
conditions which would require a scheme
to be submitted a condition could
clearly dictate the scope and or
requirements of that attenuation scheme
which would need to comply with and what
could and could not what it could and
could not contain
further the councils on reasonable
behavior is demonstrated by the time
wasted contesting and seeking to
negotiate conditions in relation to
highways matters this is notwithstanding
the fact that such conditions have been
agreed between the appellant and the
County Council in its capacity as the
highway Authority at the very most the
draft conditions that were agreed with
the highway Authority only require a
very minor amendment to include
implementation Clause here and there
which could have been easily agreed
without wholesale changes
overall
considerable wasted time was experienced
by the appellant in not just the
substantive work but also the
administrative work in seeking to agree
conditions to bring forward development
the appellant therefore seeks a partial
Award of costs for all times all wasted
time spent in that regard
so in summary overall the appellant
seeks the full Award of course
in the event costs are not awarded in
full the appellant seeks partial Award
of costs in respect of each of the above
grounds as indicated each element of
this claim is severable and independent
of the rest
okay thank you Mr Sega that's clear
um Mr Howlett are you ready to respond
to that cross application
um yes Madam I am thank you and I will
take it in the order
in which it was made is this just going
to be verbally or in writing
uh it's it's purely verbal Madam I've
had the substantive application for
about 20 minutes okay are you happy for
this one now did you need more time
I
I don't need more time to respond orally
okay I was to respond in writing I would
need significantly More Time by which I
mean I wouldn't be responding this
afternoon
foreign
thank you
yes I I I shall start with the first of
Mr stegos um substantive points which is
the
Council formally withdrawing reasons for
refuse or one three four five six and
seven
yeah
um there is in my submission a
fundamental contradiction in this ground
and if I may put it this way
um perhaps a little a little politically
but unintentionally politically
um the apparent is seeking to have its
cake and eat it on this point
if it is accepted as a premise that the
council heard in refusing the
application
on grants one three four five six and
seven
it cannot have erred again in
withdrawing them
because if the view was taken that they
were untenable
and the only proper thing to do was to
withdraw them
it is Common Ground that the
withdrawal of those
seven Grounds was communicated to the
appellant on the 14th of December
in the submission that he has just made
he criticizes the council for what he
described as the late notification of
that decision
um I do not understand the basis of that
criticism because the decision was made
at a meeting on the 13th
and therefore communicated to the adult
within 24 hours
there was no late notification of the
decision
now that left on the 14th of December
left the
apparent in the position of knowing
that reasons for refusal one three four
five six and seven
would not be
offended pursued
by the council at any time after the
14th of December
and the council in my submission in its
evidence
has been scrupulous in maintaining that
position
as I said it would be in my opening
remarks to the inquiry
and as I suggest it was throughout the
inquiry
so the decision to go on
producing
frankly massive expert evidence on all
of those matters
is a decision which the propellant made
for itself
and there is a way that that can be
measured and it is this
the appellant
introduced substantial evidence
on the question of noise attenuation
noise attenuation was never
an issue raised by the council at any
stage in the application process
at any stage in pre-application
discussions in the assessment of the
application or indeed in relation to the
appeal
and a proper inference for the parent's
decision to do that
in my submission must be
that it was anticipating third-party
representations in particular from the
action group which calls itself
kilometers rage
now
that is fine that is a decision which it
is perfectly open to a developer to make
but if it chooses to maintain
expert evidence
to the thought
Beyond matters which the council has
withdrawn
but also and this is the reason I
instanced noise
on a matter about which the council
never relied that is its prerogative
and it may well be
that that decision was informed by the
attitude of
uh killer mosh rage
but how to deal with that is a matter
for the Appellate
the cost of doing so should not then be
visited on the respondent
and I sense in Mr sagar's submission
that he may have anticipated what I've
just said and sought to get around it in
this way
by referring to the withdrawn grounds of
refusal
as matters which the council had set
running
that is to rewrite history
it is a matter of record that
from the
publication of the possibility
of this site being taken out of the
green belt
killer Marsh rage whether or not that is
when what that is what it then called
itself
strongly resisted it on any ground going
including for example
the Legacy mine working condition of the
site and the substrata beneath it
and although it's not relevant to the
issues before you
you cannot Madden have failed to pick up
the resentment
amongst killer Moss raid that this site
became the the majority of the
application site became an allocated
site and was withdrawn from the green
belt at all
but it is simply wrong
to say that those are matters which the
council had set running they had been
running long before this application
and certainly long before this appeal
so
I accept that I cannot have it both ways
whilst I make no formal concession
and I certainly do not wave privilege in
any advice which I or anyone else may or
may not have given
um if it was wrong to make the grounds
of refusal that were withdrawn
134567 in the first place
and that may leave me in difficulties up
to the date of notification of
withdrawal
it cannot follow
that uh
look at the the apparent is now entitled
to a full Award of costs in relation to
those matters as though they haven't
been withdrawn at all
and it is perhaps noteworthy
incidentally
but it was anticipated before they were
withdrawn
and this would have been an eight day
inquiry
timetable to which it may or may not
have kept
and as it is it has been technically a
full day but
certainly in terms of sitting time a
three and a half day inquiry
and it seems to me that the council
cannot be criticized as acting
unreasonably in bringing about that
State of Affairs
the council's approach in behavior in
pursuing
reason for refusal too
Mr sagos second ground
and he subdivides that firstly into what
he describes as the change of case
I make two points about that it may with
the benefit of hindsight not have been
the most felicitously worded ground of
refusal
but it is clear albeit perhaps
for the wrong reason
that the council was taking the position
that this was inappropriate development
in the green belt
and in conflict with purposes and
openness
that is the case which the appellant
had to meet knew it had to meet and
hasn't it
and it cannot be said that in substance
that uh
there has been a change of position
putting the appellant to additional
expense
in addressing what Mr Sago describes in
his written submission as a shifting
case
um
the opponent came to this inquiry ready
to meet
the argument that this was inappropriate
development on the grounds of prejudice
to openness and incompatibility with
green belt purposes it's not had to do
any extra work as a result of that
so even if there was a substantive
change of case which I do not can see
um no costs have been wasted
which are attributable to it
we are then criticized
really on
perhaps two grounds which I can take
together and they are the approach to
the test of preserving the openness of
the green belt and the council's
approach to paragraph 148 of the nppf
um and that is really that really
amounts to saying well the council got
the law rule
um I think I think Madam it was you who
in the course of the inquiry described
in fact it was the end of Mr of
councilor Foster giving his evidence you
described
um Greenbelt law and practice as not for
the faint artist
um and it may be this um after the last
three and a half days
um most of those present would tend to
agree
um with that remark
getting something wrong
is not necessarily unreasonableness
getting something wrong in a notoriously
complicated
subjective
discretionary
and I add emotional field of planning
such as the Greenbelt
is not unreasonable
an instance of that
or an illustration of the difficulties
that
Green Belt Concepts present to anyone
who has to deal with them
is that the concept of openness dates
back I believe I'm right in saying at
least to the 1947 Act
but it was certainly present in guidance
under the 1971 Act
and it was only after Sam Smith's before
the House of Lords we actually had a
definitive understanding what it meant
and even now
that decision itself gives rise to
difficulty of interpretation
particularly
in relation to the
twin-headed Hydra of spatial and visual
elements of openness
with the benefits of hindsight and the
proper scrutiny of the
the application its impact and through
the appeal process it may be of course I
do not concede it
that we fell on Greenbelt so be it
um we took a point and we failed on that
hypothesis
but that in my submission is not
unreasonable
these are matters of
subjective planning judgment
and as I shall be submitting later but I
can do it now for the purposes of this
application
um this is a matter of planning judgment
the council has put forward a planning
judgment which was properly arguable
if it fails so be it that it wasn't
unreasonable
yeah
I move then to the next substantive head
and I'm now moving away from the
approach to Greenbelt policy
and that is the council's late
introduction alleged late introduction
of arguments as to conflict with several
local plan policies that were not in the
reasons for refusal in setting out its
position in the statement of common
ground which policies were not
subsequently pursued
um
um well I can't dispute the statement of
Common Ground says what it says
and the submission made by Mr Sagar is
that the during the appeal process and
negotiations on the statement of the
Common Ground the council required
several local plan policies to be
referenced as reflecting their position
and discussed on the basis of being in
dispute they are identified
counselors fundamentally failed to
advance any case on these policies will
I accept certainly the inquiry that I
didn't on its behalf
um and then this very
broad allegations or assertion the
apparent was therefore forced to spend
considerable time reviewing these local
plan policies and ensuring the
opponent's proof of evidence address
them
the opponent therefore incurred wasted
expense through time spent addressing
additional policies which were
subsequently not referred to by the
council during the inquiry
this is a claim for a partial Award of
course new matters of argument were
introduced and not prosecuted well as to
the suggestion that the opponents
therefore forced to spend a considerable
time reviewing these local plan policies
as ensuring the opponent's proof of
evidence addressed them
um
my response to that is really a
rhetorical really
um again it's a prerogative for
a developer
but the
applicant from the application stage
onwards
has addressed every plan policy going to
the letter
um I don't concede that any
identifiable wasted costs has been
incurred through the reference to these
policies in the statement of common
ground
and if Mr Sago can identify any specific
work
that was undertaken
as a result I'd invite him to identify I
hesitant to add I'm not falling into the
Trap of asking you to assess the bill
but of course it's an important element
in any cost application
that the Appellate must must identify
firstly unreasonable behavior and
secondly
wasted expenditure
and a generalized allegation of the kind
made in
paragraph 37 of the written application
in my submission is not enough I ask
rhetorically well what did you do that
you would not otherwise have done
um
next and I think yes last head
the council's unreasonable approach to
not dealing with matters through
planning conditions
um I must confess
um I had thought when reading Mr sagar's
note that he very courteously if I may
say so presented on the first day of
inquiry so that we had some idea
um of what was coming
um I have thought
um that this might be addressed to the
process of of agreeing the conditions
themselves and the impart it is I'll
come to that
um but it appears also
um to be saying in fact well the council
should have granted planning permission
subject conditions which would require a
scheme to be submitted
um that in my submission isn't is an
unsound
um
basis to put this application because of
course at the time the scheme was
submitted
I'm sorry at the time the decision was
made
the indicative scheme before the council
was one which anticipated that the
attenuation basing area would be
available for the public access
and indeed one of the uh drawings
identifies as you look at it the right
hand that is the easternmost
attenuation Basin as a potential
kickabutt area
um so the council had no reason
um to think that by the time the
application reached stage which it has
um it would be an area free of activity
with no Public Access for anything
um and indeed Mr rollinson said in terms
I won't say that it was his decision
because of course it was his client's
decision but it was only when he came in
at a relatively late step
um that he advised and presumably his
advice was accepted
um that on Greenbelt opened this grounds
activity should be taken out of the
equation
so to say again with the benefit for
hindsight well you could have done all
this by condition
requiring us to prepare a scheme which
scheme incidentally would also have had
Expressions deal with the question of
pumping stations railings so forth
in the terms of the condition now put
forward
um it is is simply not adequate
um
particularly at the outlying stage
it is not in my submission for the
authority
to seek to condition
an application which primer face sheet
appears not to be consistent with green
belt policy and therefore unacceptable
um to to make it
acceptable in a vacuum
so again even if that is something which
the council might have done or could
have done
that's a very long way from saying that
it was actually unreasonable not to in
the circumstances and there's no real
um unreasonable behavior here
and then finally I deal with the limb of
the conditions aspect of this
application which does relate to the
handling of
the black letter of the conditions
themselves and what is said here
is what we went off to company County
Council and agreed conditions with
County Council
and that was that really you should have
accepted them well
that's an unfortunate part of the
history
um the County Council of course is not
planning Authority
and it is for the planning authority to
Grant or issues permission to accept or
reject fairness drawings and so forth
and and to
decide ultimately what conditions to be
or to be imposed it is a matter for
regret I suggest it might even be
categorized as unreasonable
that the opponent did not liaise as to
highway conditions with the County
Council and the planning Authority at
the same time
but they didn't they chose
to go to the County Council and as it
were lock in or attempt to lock in
conditions based on Derbyshire County
council's Suite or standard conditions
and then say to the planning Authority
well here you are you must agree these
I note that it is not suggested and I
will submit it properly not suggested
um the the
kind of authority in The District
Council
was wrong to have concerns about the
clarity and forcibility and
implementation
of the highways conditions and indeed
the session yesterday
um I think we're all very tired and a
bit Punch-Drunk
it was clear throughout that there was
no nothing between us as to what these
conditions highway conditions are
intended to achieve
as I understand it Matt and you decided
ultimately you could as it were all
betrayed in relation to the drafting
um
this is a non-point
um and again as to wasted costs
um the written application says
considerable wasted time was experienced
by the appellant in not just the
substantive War
but also the administrative work in
seeking to agree conditions to bring
forward the development well as far as I
can see Matt on the substantive work
done in relation to highways conditions
um involve Crossing out
um misrae's proposed amendments
and saying we stand by what the County
Council advised us
um which incidentally they didn't
yesterday because yesterday in the
course of the hearing it was accepted in
particular as to implementation that
those conditions
will require some Amendment yet it is
said well yeah we were
acting unreasonably
um in saying exactly the same thing and
offering some differently worded
conditions to achieve the same outcome
well again
though I don't concede it it is possible
that this matter could have been handled
better on both sides
these things happen
the threshold of unreasonable Comfort
doesn't come close to being in relation
to this matter
and therefore madam
for the reasons which I have given I
invite you to refuse the cost
application
as a full application and having done so
to reject the partial applications
within it as well
no so I can assess further that's how I
put it
thank you Mr Howlett
that covers all the points
uh Mr Sega did you want to respond
mom I will but I'll keep it brief
in relation to the withdrawal of the
reasons for refuse line
cannot help
but
uh come to the very clear conclusion
from what Mr Howlett has said to you
that he effectively accepts
that those reasons for refusal were
untenable from the moment that they were
imposed and that at the very least
up to the 14th of December costs are due
that's the only proper construction of
what he's just said to you
he relied upon timing to say it was not
late if it was the next day
he implied very clearly that the error
was in the refusal not the timing of
communication
that was the basis upon which she put
the point and I think it's the basis of
of the way you take that
in terms of the costs for those reasons
subsequent to the 14th of December
he has relied upon the appellant
addressing he says noise I I assume he
means air quality
because that was a matter that noise
wasn't addressed at all it wasn't even
that an issue raised by any of the local
residents but just assuming that he
means air quality for that I'm sorry if
I can interject that must have been a
moment of complete aberration of course
I meant air quality that's what I'd
assumed Mr howler that's not my point no
no I'm sure it's not but I just thought
I'd better say that having um yeah
identified the wrong so yeah don't worry
that's not my point my point is
a choice to deal with things that other
third parties raised is entirely
different from having to chase down and
spend quite a lot of time and effort on
things that were actually originally put
as reasons for refusal
not just because local third parties
were raising them but because of the
heightened and additional sensitivity of
those points because they had been
reasons for refusal because they were
points that the council had raised and
put much higher up the agenda of
important issues
in their opinion even though they
changed their mind on the matter it's a
different category and the reason we
gave evidence on that was because you
Mom have to deal with this application
as though made to you afresh
and we knew that those points which the
council had thought were potential
reasons for refusal refused it on and
then laterally withdrawn even though
councilor Foster would dearly have loved
to have had all reintroduced
were matters that we had no choice
we had a choice in relation to air or
ecology and I am not seeking costs in
relation to those matters only the
withdrawn reasons for refusal
so then I turned to the green belt
points
um
I think there's a ineffective concession
here
at this actual reason for refusal was
not the best wording
I think the truth behind that is the
case run was a different case to the
wording of the reason for refusal
I think when you look at the chronology
of what happened
there's actually quite a lot of analysis
that's gone in it's set out in Mr
rollinson's proof of the material that
was before the council at the time and
other cases that looked at the level of
material that was acceptable to other
decision makers at the time including
Poole and Huntington and the analysis of
that so Mr Howlett to say well it might
not have been that much work what he's
actually doing is trying to look at the
question of a Quantum of costs as
opposed to the principle
and um with respect to him you determine
the principle others determine the
quantum
his response in relation to the approach
to Greenbelt where he is lumped together
two points
if I can call it the openness point and
the paragraph 148 point is effectively
to say mayor Culper we got it wrong
but that's not unreasonable now
I'm afraid that just doesn't wash
that's not an excuse
the council is advised by lawyers it is
advised by professional planners it has
the ability to seek advice on matters to
determine the right way forward it had a
professional planning consultant
throughout the entirety of the inquiry
present
that person is the person who had worked
on the statement of common ground and
conditions and in relation to as I
understand it the statement of case that
has been brought by the council
and
the Sam Smith's case
which Mr Howlett now and accepts
provides a clear view on the question of
openness to what it means not the
application of it and that's not what
we're talking about
is a case that is already now several
years old
this isn't
excusable by saying we chose to defend
this case with a non-expert witness
who didn't know anything about the law
the council has to make a choice about
how it deals with its case and it is
properly advised and should have taken
the right approach
by taking the wrong approach this colors
and the entirety of the outcome
it colors the entirety of the outcome of
Mr Foster's View
and it colors the entirety of the
outcome of the council's decision-making
process throughout
if you ask the wrong question you will
get the wrong answer
um
late introduction of matters in the
statement of common ground
that is set out in some detail at Pages
um
to
page
of Mr rollinson's proof
where he sets out his views in relation
to those policy conflicts that the
council have suggested it was arguing in
the statement of common ground but then
didn't
and those paragraphs don't just write
themselves they depend upon analysis and
understanding of policy
and it isn't sufficient to say that
might not have taken that much time
again it's confusing the Quantum of the
cost with the principal
finally in relation to conditions
um I'm afraid what Mr howler has said
just sort of amplifies the point really
one of his lines of defense was that at
the time of the committee there was a
suggestion of Public Access into the
suds area
so if the council thought that made the
difference then it was quite possible to
condition the scheme so as to make that
not an invited or designed in aspect
remove the kick about area
it didn't do that
it highlights the whole point
and of course we know from other
decisions pool Huntington for example
that other decision makers including the
Secretary of State have found it quite
appropriate to impose conditions
to deal with
um Suds in Greenbelt
in order to make them acceptable
what the council has done is effectively
closed its mind to the possibility of
finding a solution
and that is unreasonable
on the highways conditions
I'm afraid we have to look at the facts
here and I think if Mr rollinson was
speaking he would probably say something
along the lines of
this
rather than engaging in adding a few
words here and there into things that
were in the agreed with the county
conditions what the council did is
rewrote the whole thing and said no
we're not engaging any more conversation
over this
my way or the highway closed its mind to
any more discussion and unfortunately
you saw how that played out yesterday
I don't need to say any more on that
thank you
thank you Mr Seger I've made detailed
notes of both of your verbal uh cost
responses there
right
um
Mr Hallett are you ready to
um present your closing
uh yes thank you madam um may I ask have
you received it I have yes thank you
very much thank you
um and I take it Mr save glass as well
so yes yes I have sorry I was muted just
giving the thumbs up sign ah thank you
uh Madam I I think I can take this
fairly briefly and I'm conscious that
you have my speaking note
um at the start of this inquiry you
identified uh the main issues as being
whether the proposal comprises
inappropriate development in the green
belt
does it preserve the openness of the
green belt
does it conflict with the purposes of
including land within the green belt
and is any potential harm to the green
belt by reason of inappropriateness and
any other harm resulting from The
Proposal clearly outweighed by other
considerations such that very special
circumstances exist
um I start with the question of
appropriate development in principle
the list of forms of not inappropriate
development in the green belt at
paragraph 150 of the framework
is a closed list
only two forms of development from that
list are in play those are engineering
operations and material changes in the
use of land
it is Common Ground that the proposal
constitutes engineering operations
um as to material change of use
of Greenbelt Land
my submission is this
um Mr rollinson in cross-examination on
this point
um was reduced to saying that the
existing use of this site the green the
green belt part of the allocation site
is grasslands that sometimes gets wet
and that after the development is
implemented if it is it will be
grasslander that sometimes gets wet
therefore no change of use
that in my submission is a remarkably
artificial
approach to the question of use and is
simply not reflective of the true
position
grassland that sometimes gets wet in my
submission is simply not a use at all it
is the nature of the land itself
and one would no more speak of using
land as grassland that sometimes gets
wet down one would speak of using
Landers and Marshals and walk out crop
if you happen to be speaking about a
marsh or a rock outcrop
and I put the matter in this way suppose
that the development does go ahead in
accordance with the application
the attenuation basins are created
and someone who
has not been to killer Marsh before
visits this area looks at the assumed
new housing estate
then look South and says oh what's that
piece of land used for
the answer I suggest
the true answer would be well their
attenuation basins
for a sustainable drainage system
um or putting it shortly flood
attenuation
that is a use
and it is not the use to which the Green
Belt part of the application site is
being put at the moment
so in my submission it is unarguable but
that there is a change of use
implicit in this proposal
um assuming that to be right
is it a material change of use
uh in my submission it would be
the land could not fulfill the new use
without its landform being altered and
without it becoming not
basins in isolation
that part of an widely engineered flood
attenuation scheme starting in the
developed area to the north of the
Greenbelt site and indeed extending so
far as the channel down to the brook is
concerned to the South as well it is a
passive use
it's not like being a playing field or a
park and ride site or whatever but
passive as it is it is nonetheless a use
maintenance visits to which passing
reference was made in evidence are
incidental to that use they are not the
main aspect of the use
um but the change in my submission
from grazing grassland to being
a part of flood attenuation scheming in
particular to having the attenuation
basins is a material change
so I both submit and in one sense
concede that potentially The Proposal
represents not inappropriate development
as engineering works and as material
change of use
whether it is actually not inappropriate
depends of course
on the issues of openness and of green
belt purposes
and before I turn to those I mentioned
briefly please
the other appeal decisions to which
reference was made in the course of the
inquiry and particular particularly in
relation to York and the York decision
at paragraph 133
um
it is no part of the respondents case
that attenuation basins are always or
are necessarily
inappropriate development in the green
belt
um that could not be our case because in
particular York and that paragraph that
say that in the circumstances of that
case the basins and I think in Europe
there was also a pond in the
wet dry distinction that we heard
yesterday
were not in appropriate development in
the green belt
there is a logical fallacy
in the Penance Reliance on those
authorities as though they
demonstrate a proposition that
attenuation basins are always a
necessary necessarily appropriate
development in the green belt
these cases are of course all site
specific
and you have to look
as you know I'm at each site on its own
merits in relation to the proposal which
is being put forward for the site in
question
and a use or
purpose which has been found to be
appropriate development on flat green
and Greenbelt and near York
may not be appropriate
um on a hilly site south of killer mosh
and in my submission it isn't for these
reasons
my deal first it was openness
we rely on the evidence of councilor
Foster
his evidence May summarize it briefly
because you heard it
is that the combination of the Earth
moving with the raising and lowering of
the existing ground level to create the
buns at the basins
together he says with the introduction
of water Mr rollinson wouldn't have that
you may have to make a decision about
that
but those elements Mr Foster said would
cause spatial change of a Kind which
would compromise the openness off the
Green Belt part of this sloping
contained site
that is a matter of planning judgment
that is the judgment to which the
planning Authority came and in my
submission it is
the correct
and in judgment
that was in a quick reference back to
the course application it is certainly a
planning judgment which was properly
open to the council to make whether or
not ultimately you agree with it
in cross-examination Mr rollinson would
not accept that the proposal would bring
about an obviously engineered landscape
um and you'll no doubt recall matter
that yesterday he and I in effect agreed
to differ
and the dry cut short my questions to
him about the various
um
I shall call them photo montages that's
not correctly what they were but you
know what I'm referring to on on the
basis that he simply disagreed as to
whether this was an obviously engineered
man-made landscape
he says not so but in my submission
however well done the creation of
man-made basins with contoured edges
will appear inevitably to be an
engineered landscape on this site
Mr Foster
said that he thought that the degree of
harm was considerable when asked by you
what he meant by that he said that
um it was in the middle of the range of
harm
and you may recall that he said madam
it's a bit appropriately and obviously
rightly that the degree of harm here
would be less than that would be created
by say a row of houses
but nevertheless in his judgment
considerable
um I suggest that his late person's word
equates to moderate in planning terms
somewhere in the middle as he said that
in answer to your question
so
um I invite you to accept that planning
judgment
this proposal if implemented would
compromise the openness of this
Greenbelt site and the green belt land
to the south of it
Astra purposes began only two in play
checking the unrestricted sprawl of
large built up areas and assisting in
safeguarding the countryside from
encroachment
councilor Foster's evidence was that the
attenuation basins represent urban
sprawl
and again there is a clear locking of
horns between him through me and Mr
Rawlinson as to that
my submission is this although as Mr
Robinson said in answer to a question in
re-examination one can and sometimes has
as such schemes in a rural context
um they are mostly and certainly
inherently
Urban
developments and here it forms part
would form part of an urban development
they would not be required here but for
Urban Development they are intrinsically
Urban in nature
and in so far as they creep across the
Great boundary what they are creeping
into is Countryside
and as such
they are both encroaching into the
countryside and failing to check sprawl
so there's really a double-headed aspect
of that and for the same reasons that
they both failed to check sprawl and
encroach into the countryside
um it follows from that if you are with
me Madam that
this is inappropriate development in the
green belt
failing to check unrestricted sprawl the
built-up error of killer Marsh failing
to assist in safeguarding the
countryside form encroachment
that being so and across 147 and 148 of
the framework are engaged
and when considering any planning
application The Authority should ensure
that substantial weight is given to any
harm to the green belt very special
circumstances will not exist unless the
potential harm to the green belt are a
reason of inappropriateness and any
other harm resulting from The Proposal
is clearly outweighed by other
considerations
uh the
I I should perhap meant perhaps mention
the question of other harms which was
raised briefly yesterday
um we don't suggest that there are other
harms
um so the application of paragraph 48 in
this case
it turns purely on consideration of the
potential harm done to the green belt
alone
I move briefly from the framework to the
Northeast Derbyshire local plan
there was some debate about whether the
list in paragraph 3 in of policy ss10 is
a closed list or not actually it doesn't
matter
whether or not it is a closed list the
policy is engaged in relation to Green
Belt arm for the same reason as
paragraphs 147 or 148 of the framework
are engaged
and again at the local policy level this
is a proposal which should not be
approved
except in very special circumstances
and this appellant does not rely does
not even allege that there are very
special circumstances
and Mr Robinson was very clear about
that when I put it to him saying in
terms special so or special
circumstances that is not my case
now if that is so if you are with me on
harm to the green belt then the matter
stops there because there are no very
special circumstances
but it may be
um that a different view could be taken
and that an attempt could be made to
point to the benefits which would flow
um from the implementation of The
Proposal on the site as a hold and in
particular on the
allocation site
and those benefits
I summarize as housing affordable
housing and the economic benefits of
construction phase employment and The
Wider economic benefits flowing from the
fact
that people move on to the new
development having money they spend some
of it in the area
um
I don't actually
abandon or Shrink from the point that
those benefits would inevitably flow
from the development of the allocation
site
um even if the Greenbelt site was not
used as part of the flood attenuation
scheme of the subs scheme
but in any event those benefits of my
submission cannot amount to very special
circumstances and the appellant was
right
not to suggest that they might
so in those circumstances
The Proposal in my submission is for is
contrary to policy ss10 of the
up-to-date local plan closed list or not
and it's contrary to the guidance in
paragraph 148 and 149 of the nppf there
are no special circumstances the appeal
should be dismissed
unless I can assist further those on my
closing remarks
thank you Mr Howlett
Mr Sega are you ready to make your
closing submissions
thank you Mum I I am
um I trust you have a copy my email but
I'm not certain if you do not yes I
haven't no it may be on its way
let me just check where we're up to
if I may interject neither have I
and I suspect had it it would have been
forwarded to me
I think it's just being sent now to
uh to all parties
um we just it might take a minute to get
across to each of you yeah
um
it's like my case officer is I'm
seriously offline all of a sudden so oh
no they're our office too
[Music]
find someone
wrote These out of office too this is
Easter for you
um
can I go to
perhaps
[Music]
foreign
she might be having some trouble
just see if there's anyone else
um
we send it to Helen Skinner will that be
of any assistance do you think she's out
of office too I'm ahead of me and let me
try somebody else
thank you
foreign
we have details for Mark Bolton Leanne
Palmer yeah Mark Wilson's out of office
as well
um
yeah Leanne karma is an option so she's
in there
okay
oops
oh okay then is typing
yes okay brilliant
ah I think she can have a look at Alice
and Dyson's inbox
so that's useful Okay so
we can send it directly Anne if you like
we've got her her yeah I think she's
actually seeing if she can get hold of
it without having to do that okay
she's pretty good Leanne
it's not that Alison isn't Allison's
brilliant too
I have a bit of a soft spot in the end
he just sent it over there we go that's
how good Leanne is
not even her area
brilliant yeah I've got it and do you
have it though Mr Howlett that's the
next thing shall I get her to send it to
you
I think you're on mute
no I've very kindly been sent directly
by Mr Speaker oh perfect okay thank you
we're good to go then
welcome man okay when you're ready then
Mr Sega thank you very much
so mum these submissions don't repeat
the opening uh statement from the
appellant I rely on all of that opening
sets out the detail of the site the
application the proposals the matters
that remain in dispute between the
appellant and the council and terms of
the officer's report which clearly
recommended approval uh so I turn to the
main issues and I think it's fairly
fairly clear what they are by this stage
through the inquiry
whether the part of the development that
is proposed within the green belt would
be an appropriate development having
regard to the framework and local
planning policy
the effect of that development on the
openness of the green belt and its
purposes
whether any harm by reason of
inappropriateness and any other harm
would be clearly outweighed by other
considerations so as to amount to very
special circumstances and the overall
planning balance
and there are a number of issues raised
by Third parties interested parties
these masses have been thoroughly
addressed and responded to by the
Appellate both in writing and through
calling expert from several expert
Witnesses expert evidence from several
expert Witnesses these matters are
returned to in more detail later
the appellant has also addressed each of
the six reasons to refuse or the council
withdrew on the 14th of December as the
appeal had to proceed as a result of the
refusal and notwithstanding the
council's withdrawal of six of its seven
reasons
the appellant had no real choice but to
deal with those matters the appealers of
course amounted to be determined by you
as though an application had been made
to you in the first place
so I turned to the main issue the green
belt case and I set out the appellant's
position
for refusal 2 relates to the very small
part of the site in the green belt it
relates to the claimed absence of
information and the details of the
proposals in that area it proceeds on
the basis that without further
information the proposal should be
assumed to be contrary to Green Belt
policy it is an agreed matter that the
law requires
reasons for refusal to be clear precise
and full
the appellants case has been very
clearly set out in the evidence of Mr
rollinson the amount of information
provided was ample and proportionate to
the planning application being an
outline
that was accepted both by the policy
officer and the case officer at the time
as is clearly set out in those in in the
paperwork associated with those parties
the information available was in line
with other appeal decisions
and then without prejudice additional
illustrative material was submitted on
the 3rd of February and that
demonstrably shows how the bozeals meet
national green belt policy and local
policy
Mr rollinson's written evidence
addresses reasons refusal to and
concludes that the council have taken an
inappropriate approach to considering
the attenuation basins in the green belt
his written evidence can be found on
this topic in his proof Pages 25 to 49.
Mr rollinson in his evidence in Chief
explained a number of key fundamentals
firstly
the drainage strategy that underlies the
reason the suds basins extend partly
into the green belt approximately by 20
meters about half of their width
and this is due to the Topography of the
site with an existing Valley formed in
the southern edge of the site and the
remediated Connery spoil Mound Beyond
the strong policy encouragement for
surfs the location of the existing
ponding in this area with both water
from the site itself and the colliery's
spoil Mound
and the need to address existing
flooding issues caused by water
collecting in this area and flowing down
the former colliery access road to Green
Lane
there are clear and cogent drainage and
topographical reasons for the basins to
be located where they are proposed the
effect of the scheme is a betterment of
some 60 in drainage and flood risk terms
compared to the existing situation
he also explained the proposed basins
are clearly engineering operations this
matter is now accepted by the council
consequently nppf 150 is fully engaged
such that the basins are appropriate
development provided they preserve
openness and do not conflict with green
belt purposes
even if it was concluded that the
proposals amounted to a material change
of use
Mr Robinson says they're not given
existing and proposed nature of use they
would in any event be covered by nppf
150 On and On Any proper reading of
local plan policy
ss103 as well
that is an open list of acceptable
exceptions which follows that which
allows that policy to be easily read as
consistent with mvpf paragraph 150.
Mr rollinson also explained that the
correct approach to the application
consideration of nppf 150 is such that
once development is just appropriate
there is no second test of applying
substantial weight to any harm to the
green belt and to do so would be wrong
in law this now appears despite
councilor Foster's confusion on the
matter to be an agreed approach as
explained by Mr Howlett in his
cross-examination of Mr rollinson
Mr rollinson further explained that the
correct approach to judging if openness
is preserved is to accept that policy
and npps 150 has defined certain things
as appropriate in the green belt
these will cause change to openness that
change is acceptable up to a threshold
the want beyond which there could be
judged to be a lack of preservation
this is not only the obvious consequence
of considering each of the matters set
out in nppf 150 some of which will
inevitably have very significant defense
on openness but it is also the approach
in case law and is the approach endorsed
in all other cases before the inquiry
openness does not imply freedom from
development if it did paragraph 150
would be meaningless
in this case applying the correct
approach and the correct understanding
of policy Mr rollinson has assessed the
appeal scheme by reference to his
appendix 3 id4 appendix 7 and appendix 8
and these collectively show first the
small area of Greenbelt affected see
appendix 7 a matter relevant in the
context of the Euro garages case which
makes it clear it is the effect on the
Green Belt not just the site as such
that needs to be taken into account
secondly the fact that there is not
proposed to be anything other than
ground remodeling in the green belt and
that this can be controlled by condition
thirdly the low gradients with a maximum
of one in four and only in one instance
created by the ground modeling works
when id4 was the annotated long section
is properly understood
the fact that ground raising will be
below and tie into the surrounding land
that is in the green belt and will use
the natural topography to create
naturalistic undulations is also seen in
the cross sections of his appendix 3.
he refers to the occasional water
storage in this area which is a
naturally occurring feature and doesn't
itself affect openness indeed as
proposed it would be only some three or
so times a year that there would be any
water in it to speak of at all
he explains that it's difficult to
contemplate that Suds engineering
operations that could have any lesser
spatial effect on openness given the
scheme and it's locally surrounding
topography
he also explains that the very localized
areas from which the subs Basin could be
seen particularly when the allocated
housing site is developed
results in a very limited visual effect
shown clearly in the montages in his
appendix Aid these montages as explained
in detail by Mr walshaw and set out in
id10 are not artists impressions as
suggested by councilor Foster they are
from accurate survey and use the scheme
design to precisely show the visual
effects of the basins over this very
limited and very restricted area of view
they show the fallacy of counselor
Foster's suggestion that there would be
damned walls
the scheme is subtle and natural it does
not block views up or down the existing
small Valley created by the spoil Heap
in the green belt indeed as councilor
Foster accepted you can't tell from
these photos that there's anything there
whilst he had no valid basis for
criticizing their accuracy
in terms of green belt purposes Mr
rollinson was very clear that the key
part of purpose 138 a was to check
unrestricted sprawl the checking
function is what the green belt should
do this is not undermined by the appeal
proposals indeed the converse is true
the basins will be a permanent feature
that can't be built on at least for the
life of the Housing Development
in terms of encroachment in the
countryside the basins do not create any
realistic encroachment and will prevent
it in the future
so the green belt's ability to continue
to serve its role as checking sprawl and
safeguarding the countryside from
encroachment will not be undermined by
these proposals it will indeed be
enhanced and the ability to control the
development and achieve a green belt
compatible scheme by the imposition of
conditions does seem now in principle to
be accepted by the council and quite
rightly so unfortunately it hasn't been
in the past
and so um
that's Mr rollinson and the appellants
Greenbelt case I contrast it with the
council's approach
councilor Foster chose to give evidence
on a complex policy topic despite no
policy expertise having not dealt with
any similar case and certainly not as an
appeal this was so notwithstanding the
council being represented by an external
planning consultant
he was also a main mover in the original
refusal and was clearly akin to try to
fight the case on all original reasons
for refusal despite the fact that the
council had legal advice to the country
including after the risk of costs being
awarded against it
is find the illustrative additional
materials submitted on the 3rd of
February this year by the appellant has
agreed at the case management conference
in an attempt to give the council yet
further clarity
to the very modest nature of the effects
of the green belt with the council
indicating in its statement of common
ground that it would consult on this
material and seek advice of others
councilor Foster in spite of that could
not explain why this had not happened
why that consultation did not take place
and it appears that he alone alone has
decided to press on with the argument
although the reasons for refusal are
clearly expressed as being about a lack
of detail to make a judgment and the
Assumption of inappropriateness as a
result
that is clearly not now how the case is
being run there was never a request for
more information from officers or the
council prior to the refusal admission
there is however now a reluctant
acceptance that conditions could have
addressed many of the items of
development structures and buildings for
example that the council appeared at the
point of a refusal to be concerned about
and by precluding them from being
allowed in the green belt
surprisingly though all of these items
still feature large in the councilor's
evidence
despite clear legal authority to the
contrary it appears that councilor
Foster's proof was drafted on the basis
that very substantial weight had to be
given to any green belt arms in the
context of determining whether the terms
of paragraph nppf 150 are met
preservation of openness and not
conflicting with its purposes
whilst that matter is clearly confused
him in cross-examination with acceptance
of the error followed by denial it's now
conceited by Mr Howlett in his
cross-examination of Mr Rollins however
the point doesn't rest there it appears
the council misdirected itself and
approached the matter in the wrong way
which will inevitably have colored the
outcome of its Judgment at the time of
refusal at the time of reinstatement of
the intention to find reason two in
December and in the way it's put its
case to this inquiry
to compound that
that particular misdirection there is an
even more fundamental one the
understanding of what preserved the
openness of the Greenback means
to suggest as councilor Foster does that
preservation of openness requires an
effect that is neutral not at all
negative not even to the smallest degree
is a serious error of policy
interpretation
councilor Foster could not explain where
he'd got that notion from and could
point to no policy case or decision that
supported it
it is not consistent with the framework
or the local plan and certainly is
inconsistent with the views of the
Supreme Court
it is also dramatically different to the
approach in recent appeal decisions and
in those local Authority decisions that
have been upheld as lawful by the courts
not only is this an incorrect
interpretation of policy inevitably that
has inevitably colored the council's
approach to this case but the
characterization of the effect of The
Proposal on the Green Belt has been
dramatically overstated
that's typified by the claim that the
effects on the Green Belt would be
considerable
and a misreading of the section drawings
by councilor Foster leading him to form
the view there will be damned Walls
Within the scheme
councilor Foster's proof is also
littered with suggestions of things
being proposed in the green belt but he
knows full well are not shown on the
plans and can be conditioned to be
excluded
councilor Foster's suggestion that the
mere fact of a cut and fill exercise
will increase the volume of material in
the green belt and so not preserve
openness is firstly the accepts a guess
secondly in any event takes no account
of the fact that the site is in fact the
whole site the development site for
housing where cut material can be sold
elsewhere
and in any event misses the obvious
point that a neutral person feel
balanced within the subs area in the
Green Mount by definition results in a
neutral effect on openness anyway
in visual terms it's clear that
counselors councilor Fosters an
effective agreement with Mr rollinson
the views of the part of the subs area
in the green belt will be localized
um you're able to go further south than
the spoiled Heap in order to see for
yourself even as far as think Hill on
your sign visit but you won't be able to
see the land on which the basins are
proposed let alone the part of that
which is in the green belt from those
locations
in terms of Greenbelt purposes it seems
the Zenith of the council's case is that
must be Urban because the name suggests
this and because the use is related to
residential development
this fails in a really fundamental way
to ask how this scheme in this location
undermines the greenbelt's role in terms
of the ability to check sprawl and
Safeguard the countryside for
encroachment
Time and Again The Counselor seems to
suggest that the Greenbelt boundary was
being moved instead of setting out how
the proposal conflicted with Greenbelt
performing its purposes
councilor Fosters other examples of
sudsy sex tonight in his appendix to
don't Advance any understanding of the
effects of the appeal scheme they are
not remotely similar examples in
location type or design
in contrast Mr rollinson's rebutler to
appendix D for a scheme he was involved
with last page of that appendix provides
a much more comparable scheme
further counselor Foster's change of use
argument is groundless
firstly it's based on a misunderstanding
of ss10 as a policy the word include
could not be more obvious as a signpost
of an open list however even if
counselor the counselor was correct
he would have identified the policy that
would have identified the policy
inconsistent with nppf and therefore out
of date with reduced weight applying to
it
if actual effects of the use of such
basins are in any event if material is a
change of use clearly de minimis the use
should not be conflated with merely
restating concerns about Earth moving
which is all that councilor Foster did
in making that point in his proof
finally of course there's councilor
Foster's point about the local plan
process and whilst this was put with
much gusto in the council's opening and
the councilor's evidence in Chief
on analysis it was done so on a
misunderstanding of the facts
whilst the original representation to
the local plan included a master plan
that appeared to show the basins in the
allocation this was based on preliminary
work in February 2018
developed into detailed work by the time
of the application being lodged some
eight months later as explained in
inquiry document 9 and by Mr rollinson
in Chief
by October 2018 the application that
forms this appeal was lodged and this
had the suds essentially as they are now
in the submissions to the examination of
the local plan harworth responded to the
inspectors questions about flooding and
drainage by reference to the current
application and its supporting
information referencing the application
directly
this was simply subsequently relied upon
by the inspector as recorded in her
report stating that the site could
accommodate at that time 393 dwellings
based on the technical reports submitted
with the now appeal application
the most realistic interpretation of
these facts is that the council and the
inspector were fully aware of the
intention to locate the subspaces in the
Greenbelt and were not concerned that
this needed a different allocation
boundary given the position
experienced practitioners would take to
such a matter and the common nature of
Suds in the green belt how slow
there were subtly different point the
comment from the local plan inspector at
paragraph 182 about reinforcement of the
Southern hedge Road and careful Green
Space planning
is
planning to assist in mitigating the
visual effects of the housing
development and creating a strong Green
Belt boundary is consistent with these
proposals as explained by Mr rollinson
indeed that is what the appeal scheme
does
so mama and I turn it to other matters
non-green belt matters I suppose not the
main issues by definition
and I'm going to take this slightly more
quickly and largely as read
one matter that was underlying reason
for refusal one was conflict with policy
lc1
there's an agreed position and a
statement of Common Ground the council's
argument was run and lost at the
Primrose Lane appeal inquiry in that
case the inspector awarded costs against
the council for running that argument
and I quote in the written submission
what the inspector said on the point
public transport
it was a reason for refusal it should
never have been this is a recently
allocated site in the adopted local plan
uh the suggestion that is not located so
as to have good enough access to local
transport seeks to ignore the allocation
the whole point of the local plan
process is to choose the best sites in
all the circumstances they may not be
perfect we have to live in a real world
that's what the local plan inspector did
and when she comments that there were
some aspects not not suboptimal that
cannot be construed as unacceptable
otherwise the allocation wouldn't have
been confirmed
I set out for Imam for your for your
note where in the statement of common
ground and the evidence you will find
answers to all of those points
traffic looks the same but what Mr Blair
has done he hit it is that he has gone
back
to the County Council to make sure that
his position is understood and agreed by
them as the highway Authority and it is
he has demonstrated that the actual
level of traffic growth has been less
than expected at the time of the
original ta
that the future growth is now less than
was predicted
that the actual traffic generation rates
are lower that traffic speeds are lower
and that there's been no material change
in accidents recorded and as a
consequence of doing considerable work
in relation to the capacity of Junctions
links and new accesses is quite content
as is the County Council that there will
not be a problem
in relation to off-site Junctions and we
did touch on this briefly yesterday
there is one Junction where there is a
question about the need for it to be
improved
that isn't Bridge Street and Sheffield
Road
and so the approach agreed is that
further assessment is to be taken when
before 200 homes are occupied to see if
Improvement is necessary and if and
using the language of nppf110 it is
necessary to cost effectively mitigate
any significant impacts
the cost-effective mitigation scheme
within the adopted Highway and
incorporating controlled pedestrian
Crossing facilities is to be submitted
for approval and implemented
Mr Sega is that the condition that is
the condition
I forget I forget the number that's okay
that's enough for me to piece it
together yes that is the condition
well in terms of mining
great deal of information provided coal
Authority fully engaged coal Authority
fully satisfied
um it's um a situation that isn't
unusual Mr Friel has considerable
experience of similar situations
including situations where some recorded
mine entries aren't found at the outline
stage
the matter is conditioned and the
process of looking for and sometimes not
finding them is overseen by the coal
Authority
education again a high level of
agreement the issue really only relates
to the need to provide a contribution
for special education needs
the primary schools in killer Marsh have
a massive amount of spare capacity and
the only issue is that Saint Giles the
closest school has a more limited
capacity but still a surplus of 41
places
but the other school killer Marsh
infants and juniors as a surplus of some
180 spaces in combination far more than
is needed to accommodate the development
and the difference between the two is
that one is 500 meters further away
in terms of doctors and health again a
fully resolved matter
the contribution has been calculated in
line with a formula the formula is
endorsed by the council's infrastructure
delivery plan
the latest iteration of the calculation
as one figure change that's the build
cost we discussed yesterday
and the way that that has been
calculated is for all 397 dwellings so
as the consequence the section 106
proceeds on the basis of each dwelling
paying one
397th of the total cost
um Mr rollinson's Health Care statement
does however demonstrate that across the
relevant GP practices in the local area
there is capacity without improvements
so again one could form the view that
the situation is similar to the
education issue for primary schools
capacity overall just not at the closest
GP
um similar to the Giles point I
mentioned a moment ago
in terms of public rights of way of
course this is an outline application
the actual alignment of development and
the treatment of footpaths is a matter
for later but the current illustrative
master plan shows all paths retained
without diversion they are not retained
on footways besides rows that go through
green corridors save of course the way
they Crossroads which is inevitable in
order to accommodate the allocation
and Mr walshaw's statement identifies
how the paths have been
dealt with treated and provides
considerable detail
he also responds to the position of
local residents
flood risk and drainage
again a matter of statement of common
ground
and I refer you to the statement of Mr
Parks until id9 when he responded to
some of the points raised by local
residents on day one of the inquiry air
quality
I refer you to the statement of Common
Ground
the air quality assessment of read more
and the response to the local residents
criticisms of that in id7
ecology again a matter all agreed I
refer you to Mr Baker's statement and
his ID 11 which responds fully to all
the matters that have been raised by
local residents
and I reiterate the scheme will provide
a net gain for hedgerows of 128.8
percent and a net gain otherwise of 6.93
and this is achieved both on-site and
off-site
and
um we loaded it yesterday the fourth
appendix to Mr Baker's uh
updated ecology report contains the
plans of what and where is intended
Heritage I mentioned briefly uh the
effect on listed buildings is not a
matter of concern to local residents or
the council but of course there's a
statutory Duty comes to them
to address that are directly to the
statement of common ground to Mr
rollinson's proof and to the core
documents and I've listed them to give
you some signposts as to where I think
you need to look of course you now have
the listings of the relevant buildings
and we say there are essentially three
located
um next to and include West Thorpe
Farmhouse they are separated from the
site physically and Visually on there on
the other side of West Thorpe Road from
it
any effects on significance are agreed
to be negligible and readily outweighed
by the public benefits of bringing
forward the allocation
so then we turn to the balance
the appellant doesn't seek to suggest
there are very special circumstances
because there is no need to the proposal
fully occurs with the development plan
and the framework section 38 6 of the
plan of sorry of the ACT requires the
determination to be made in accordance
with the plan and the nppf requires that
development is approved without delay
the appeal scheme Accords with ss10 of
the local plan and nppf 150. however
there are a number of significant
benefits and although there are some
matters that need consideration on the
negative side of the equation these are
as explained by Mr Rollins and
essentially neutral
pretty well each of the benefits is
acknowledged by the council the
difference is a matter of weight and the
council's position is that if there was
another scheme to come forward that
didn't include any Greenbelt Land it
would be approved and so the benefits of
this scheme are limited to the
difference but
the council's approach I say is wrong
for a series of reasons there's only one
application before you there's only one
planning application and only one appeal
and it's this one
that's application has already taken
five years to get to this point and we
still don't have planning permission on
an allocated side
and the council has shown a clear
propensity supported by rage who clearly
consider the allocation of the site in
the plan as an error and can't come to
terms with it to refuse permission for
all sorts of other reasons indeed
counselor Foster in particular would
happily have seen the appeal defended by
the council for all seven of the
original reasons even in the face of
legal advice to the country
so Mom the whole notion of proceeding on
the basis of marginal benefits doesn't
stack up with the facts and the history
here
further
the housing needs are not a maximum and
land Supply needs to continue to be
provided for maintaining a five-year
loan Supply is an ongoing matter
affordable housing needs exist here and
now the council's approach was saying we
can't meet the full needs and though
there is a massive and increasing
waiting list little weight should be
given to attempts to address it is
simply missing the point
there are substantial benefits from
attempting to meet those needs now
employment benefits also derived from
the development and its related spin-off
investment and spending these benefits
are fully consistent with the
Regeneration policies for kilimash in
the local plan the benefits of
ecological games are also significant so
too the school and drainage points
raised by Heather Nola and Alex parks in
their evidence the school Point mom is
not about
weight to the monetary contribution
it's making sure that in the case of the
killing killer Marsh infants and Junior
School which is so many Surplus spaces
it actually has enough children in it to
keep and maintain its viable future
in addition new accessible public open
space far above policy requirement is at
least of modest weight
the appellant submits that whilst these
masses do not amount to very special
circumstances they are nevertheless
significant in the overall balance and
are in favor of the appeal being allowed
a mum for all of these reasons the
opponent respectfully asks that the
appeal will be allowed and that you
grant planning
thank you
okay thank you very much
I think that's
really uh the end of all the formal
business in this inquiry
um so that really just leaves me to say
um
just really to thank everybody and
for your conduct during the inquiry
um I've already mentioned this but the
interested parties you organize
themselves very well and behaved
impeccably and on what is clearly
um very important issues to them so
thank you for that because it does make
the running of an inquiry easier and it
actually makes it easier to understand
your points of view
um and just generally thank you for
everyone for your hard work this week
because I think it's been quite a a
fairly busy week um even though it's a
relatively short inquiry and thanks for
your flexibility in moving
um online when we did overrun today and
um particularly thanks to the council
for being able to set that up
um late notice and generally the venue
and this virtual
um Forum have worked really well so
thank you for that
I think that's all I really have to say
um so really that just leaves me now
unless there is anything anyone wanted
to say finally
um just just I mean the local residents
probably won't want this from me but I
endorse what you just said I think they
did Marshal their thoughts very
precisely clearly and um and good for
them the fact that I don't agree with
their position is a different matter
yeah I absolutely agree and I mention it
because I've seen interested parties not
live in such an organized and and well
organized Manner and it really does help
inquiries if they can do I appreciate
you know that it's difficult for them
um but they've done remarkably well in
the circumstances so thank you for
acknowledging that
okay
if there's nothing further then um
I'm just going to say that the inquiry
is closed now and a decision will follow
in due course so thank you thank you
good afternoon good afternoon good
afternoon